[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous l'invité de
sao qu'a dit ce matin rutali contrôle
bonjour bonjour vous êtes la directrice
de la davie mg-france victimes
l'association départementale d'aidé aux
victimes
quelles sont les missions de la davie et
la davie me porte
mais en oeuvre sur le territoire la
politique publique des deux victimes sur
en france le choix a été fait dès les
années 80 avec le ministère de la
justice pour que ce soit les
associations d'aidé aux victimes
singulièrement qui porte cette politique
publique sur l'ensemble du territoire
la devinette composé de kick-ass conquis
on retrouve au sein de l'association
on retrouve à la davie mme comme dans
tous les services des deux victimes
une équipe pluridisciplinaire composée
de juristes de psychologues et de
travailleurs sociaux
pourquoi parce que simplement on a une
mission dite de prise en charge globale
centrée sur les différentes situations
de la victime qui peut être économiques
socio économique santé psychologique et
un accompagnement dans les démarches et
ça au plus près des faits suite à
l'infraction alors justement tous bien
compris ne faut pas confondre l'adav
humaines et paie une association de
victimes c'est une association dead mais
quand on parle de victime
de quoi parle-t-on exactement alors
ici on parle de victimes surtout dans le
sens juridique du terme c'est-à-dire
toute personne qui a certes subi un
préjudice mais du fait du non respect
d'une loi pénale c'est important de
reconnaître d'être reconnus victimes de
reconnaître le statut de victime oui
tout à fait c'est une étape importante
pour la victime
dans le cadre de sa préparation le
procès ne va pas réparer complètement la
victime et va y contribuer puisque le la
mission du process et sanctionner réparé
par le biais de l'indemnisation qui sera
alloué à la victime il ya
obligatoirement procès alors hippen il
peut ne pas y avoir procès si par
exemple l'auteur n'a pas été identifié
et la séance est difficile de se
reconstruire
quand lindon on a été victime justement
d'une agression par exemple et que
l'auteur n'a pas été appréhendé n'a pas
été identifié oui c'est forcément
difficile pour la victime mais le rôle
de des services des deux victimes
justement avec le psychologue qui
intervient et d'accompagner la victime à
se restructurer et ça même si il n'y a
pas de procès un puisque le procès n'est
qu'une étape 1
dans la reconstruction d'une victime ça
passe pas pourquoi vous vous accompagnez
jury au feu vous accompagner dans toutes
les démarches
comment la prise en charge se fait
exactement alors la prise en charge se
fait par des intervenants que j'ai cité
des juristes des travailleurs sociaux ou
encore des psychologues
d'abord il est posé un diagnostic avec
la victime sur sa situation
à partir de là on va déterminer avec
elles si vraiment déjà elle est une
victime dans le sens juridique du terme
si oui on va lui proposer un plan
d'accompagnement en fonction de sa
situation
ça peut être une orientation vers une
structure spécialisée
si c'est le cas je prends le cas d'une
victime de violences conjugales un point
hébergement par exemple mais l'aide aux
victimes sera référente tout au long du
parcours de cette victime jusqu'à
l'indemnisation jusqu'à la fin du procès
combien de personnes vous recevez
globalement et deux parmi les personnes
que vous recevez combien de victimes il
ya alors l'année dernière par exemple
nous avons reçu 1350 de personnes et sur
ses 1352 il y avait
mille cent cinquante victimes
majoritairement des femmes plus de 750
ce sont des femmes est constituée
surtout de violence d'atteintes aux
personnes date est être à familiale de
violences intrafamiliales et la force
des services des deux victimes jeudi
green n'est pas ta du que notre mission
est de recevoir toute personne qui
s'estime victime d'une infraction
quand vous dites est très familial c'est
quoi mais la violence intrafamiliale
peut être caractérisé une part la
violence conjugale par exemple mais pas
seulement ça peut être la violence des
enfants envers leurs parents ça
peut-être
dans la famille vous avez des familles
qui vivent sous plusieurs générations
des frères et soeurs dans sur un petit
une petite parcelle par exemple tout ça
constitue des violences intrafamiliales
est ce que les gens ont le réflexe de
venir de faire appel à vous alors pas
suffisamment si les victimes ont besoin
d'être protégés soutenus et aidés
elles ne font pas cette démarche de
manière systématique pourtant il y a eu
des progrès puisque depuis quelques
années
les coordonnées lada vim
enfin d'un service d'aidé aux victimes
figurent sur les dépôts de plainte et ou
encore la personne et on lui propose de
s'orienter vers un avocat si elle
inscrite seulement les victimes ne font
pas cette démarche systématiquement
c'est souvent la veille de l'audience
qu'elles vont se rapprocher du bureau
d'aidé aux victimes pour avoir des
informations ou encore après le jugement
parce qu'il ya eu des dommages et
intérêts et souhaite connaître les
démarches à effectuer pour recouvrir les
sommes qui leur sont dues
vos compétences ont été élargies aux
catastrophes naturelles
vous êtes intervenu notamment dans lors
du passage dire ma oui tout à fait le
service d'aidé aux victimes a été
mobilisé au niveau national par le
ministère de l'outre-mer notamment pour
accompagner instruire des dossiers sur
un fonds spécifique qui avait été qui
était dédiée pour ces victimes là et
donc toutes les victimes qui étaient sur
le territoire y en avait on a reçu à peu
près une dizaine de victimes
et donc on a inscrit leur dossier
transmis au ministère de la justice est
à ce jour de mémoire elles ont toutes
été indemnisés ou d'accord ce qui est un
profil socioprofessionnel des victimes
que vous que vous que vous recevez ben
non contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait
croire parce qu'il s'agit d' aide aux
victimes
non
ça touche toutes les catégories
socioprofessionnelles de la population
et même des personnes publiques des
personnes morales pendant qu'ils
viennent également nous consulter pour
avoir des informations sur leurs droits
les chômeurs par exemple ne représente
qu'un tiers de la population que nous
recevons la grande majorité ce sont des
personnes actives
d'accord on a parlé nisation qu'est-ce
qu'il arrive si l'auteur des faits n'est
pas solvable
alors il ya plusieurs dispositifs
d'indemnisation qui existent nous avez
la commission d'indemnisation des
victimes qui peut intervenir pour les
infractions graves 1 comme le vol
le voleur millet mais surtout les
homicides les viols la commission peut
se substituer à l'auteur et les lui
éviter toute cette démarche vers le
recouvrement des sommes qui lui sont
dues par contre pour les victimes du
quotidien les autres 1
il ya également un autre dispositif qui
est d'ailleurs assez récents puisqu'ils
datent de décembre 2008
me semble t'il
et donc qui permet à toute personne
victime d'obtenir d'être accompagnés en
tout cas dans cette démarche-là et
d'obtenir une partie de la somme qui lui
a été alloué par le tribunal et ensuite
le fonds de garantie puisqu'il s'agit de
lui se retourne contre l'auteur pour
récupérer les sommes qui sont dues tri
alors demain vendredi 25 octobre à 16
heures à l'hôtel batelière vous
organiser une conférence sur le thème
quels accompagnements suite à des morts
violentes
elle sera animée par carole damiani
docteur en psychologie clinique c'est
pas ce n'est pas un thème facile parce
qu'on va parler du day 6 ha oui tout à
fait vous savez les homicides les
suicides et accidents collectifs
engendre des traumatismes chez les
survivants et des deuils
particulièrement douloureux pour les
familles donc il s'agit pour nous à
travers cette conférence de vulgariser
un petit peu l'accompagnement qu'ils
aient fait spécifiquement dans ce
domaine de l' annonce de la mort
jusqu'au procès quand il y à un procès
nous passerons en revue toutes les
pratiques de l'aide aux victimes
c'est quand par exemple eu que comme
comme on arrive à se reconstruire
quand on par exemple l'auteur des faits
n'a pas été retrouvée et qu'on a perdu
je suis pas un proche
qu'est-ce que quels mécanismes ont une
foule
il faut mettre en place dans ces cas là
o khaled objective propose un
accompagnement soutien psychologique
dans le long terme qui va permettre à
cette personne d'une part de verbaliser
ccc ressenti les lie
la douleur qui est enfoui en elle
pendant et surtout de pouvoir s'exprimer
un même endroit les importants dans ces
cas là la parole est importante parce
qu'il faut que la victime puisse
exprimer librement son ressenti même
s'il n'y a pas de procès bien fait qui a
marqué beaucoup les martiniquais vous
êtes intervenu dans ce cas là c'est le
crash de maracaibo oui oui tout à fait
les services d'aidé aux victimes un rôle
important en cas de catastrophes
collectives
en effet dans ce cas précis nous sommes
intervenus pour notamment recensé les
personnes décédées leur famille en lien
avec le parquet puisque dans ce type
d'événement nous sommes saisis par le
procureur de la république pour mettre
en oeuvre un accompagnement de ce type
de victime et il y à aussi diverses
façons de faire sont deux il n'y a pas
une censure type d'être en deuil non non
le deuil peut générer il peut être
compliqué ça peut être un deuil
traumatique voir post traumatique si la
personne a vu la mort
oui c'est compliqué alors je rappelle
que c'est donc votre conférence est donc
vendredi 25 octobre à 16 heures à
l'hôtel batelière madame brut kotalik
contrôle je vous remercie
excellente journée à l'autre mais c'est
moi notre de nos programmes